pas
amis
pourquoi eh bien nous à nous réunit ce
soir autour de notre schlim bucs autre
chemin- but qui n'a pas encore été
découvert celui vu que la france entière
dressa vers ce qu'il est et hier très
peur nos amis de montlhéry ont bien
failli faire tomber sauce l'hymne but et
voilà
la fête je vous rappelle que nous sommes
au début de cette 78ème semaine
peut-être le stream butte va-t-il tomber
ce soir
on connaît maintenant la somme
rondelette de 143 1400 francs lourd et
bien nous sommes ce soir au bourget amis
du bourget
zaghib on s'habille nous entende et
j'admire les spectateurs et la
définition exacte du slim bucs se trouve
à l'intérieur de cette enveloppe
une anecdote il est ici un monsieur qui
comme depuis trois jours je crois qu'il
a trouvé le slim des filles qui je crois
qu'ils les magasins même continuer
d'ouvrir la boîte moss faire très chaud
débat dastic vous avoue le premier
candidat s'est montré bien oui monsieur
très bien on n'avait pas changé aux est
toujours aussi beau s'il est ce que je
peux vous poser ma question maintenant
je voudrais savoir si le schmilblick
si l'euro mais les le connaissez par
exemple les romances vous dit quelque
chose
les romains judicieux bien surpris si
les romains attendez je vais me tourner
vers mon avis écoutez monsieur de toute
façon nous allons vous vous dire que les
romains devait devait connaître je pense
d dans des proportions et dans des
conditions un peu différente ce n'est
pas tout à fait le même que si nous
présentons aujourd'hui les algayon
inscrite en faux et on va vous demander
à quai à kehl
quel objet vous pensiez monsieur mais
voilà qui monsieur linux je pensais à la
machine à gonfler les ballons à gonfler
les ballons
non non non j'ai pas nous sommes désolés
non tant pis pour vous alors monsieur je
suis bien content nous a revu quand même
et nous aussi on va me suis-je bonne
santé merci concurrents suivants shirt
ailleurs qu' il pèse plus de 900 grammes
votre chevelure muc 900 grammes vous
avez des pêcheurs oui oui monsieur il
pèse plus de 900 grammes une cartouche
et en vue de dessus alors les données
non ajustées passera du toit n 4 le but
de bons papiers monsieur alors deuxième
question s'il vous plaît bon ben j'en ai
prendre je vois pas le choix concurrents
suivants nom mademoiselle non non
absolument désolé non ça n'est pas ça du
tout non concurrence et le monde
bonsoir bonsoir qui soutient aussi qu'il
n'est pas bon quelle différence y at-il
entre une musique s'il vous plaît entre
le cheveu bloqués et quoi bon
elles sont censées à l'athéisme public
du public
oui monsieur on s'en sert bien entendu
voilà s'en prendre à leurs interventions
l'autre question est ce qu'on s'en
cherche qu'à la télé du cheveu behike
est-ce qu'on sert qu'à la télé c'était
une excellente c'est une excellente des
questions ça oui oui monsieur on s'en
sert qu'à la télé alors essayé de donner
une définition s'il vous plaît ne venez
pas à jeter pour pour faire avancer le
public écoutez monsieur alors envers
monsieur merci beaucoup et je vous
rappelle que m notre public est
maintenant passé à 145 mille francs est
ce que le smilblick at il un rapport
avec le bonnet
avec le avec le bonheur
oui oui et oui et non pas dans un
certain sens écoutée on rajoute quand
même 100 francs elle n'est ce pas et à
quoi pensez-vous
ah c'est très intelligent ça oui je vous
félicite jean van hamme
mais malheureusement voyez-vous non non
ça n'est pas allé vous une autre
question
non mais j'en profite pour dire bonjour
attendu cette attente on s'y met on ya
tous mes camarades de vézin le coquet et
de marnes-la-coquette le concurrent
suivante on sent alors non et non désolé
c'est terminé pour vous et bien ouvert
envers monsieur un mois après l'appel à
la concurrence
bonjour guy lux oui je voudrais savoir
si je pourrai retrouver au salon
international des arts ménagers salon
international
et à quoi pensiez-vous tout temps c'est
un jeu alors à quoi pensiez-vous madame
des petits pois congelés photographié à
l'envi sur un plateau non madame non non
pas des petits pois rappel merci
concurrents suivants d'itway oui est ce
que je me loupe serait pas une fin de
régime artisans now ou flamande
un monsieur s'est désolé mais j'ai
l'impression que vous êtes étranger
n'est ce pas infirmatif et bien les
règles de notre jeu sont formels nous
devons accepter que des concurrents
français nous sommes désolé cher
monsieur vous êtes très fair play
merci de votre visite à bientôt voir
monsieur qu'est ce qu'on fait peut-être
à non madame non désolé madame on va
madame championne est-ce que leslie plus
qu'un rapport avec un mirage des mirages
jeu les avions chargés lui la question
est intéressante et et à quoi
pensez-vous
un mirage oui désolé ça dépend
monsieur monsieur est ce que le chum
bucca rapport avec les dépressions avec
les dépressions oui monsieur wissant
france de danse et dépression nerveuse
et du goudron non pas de celle qui nous
viennent d'irlande la plupart du temps à
leur mort n'ont alors là je suis désolé
monsieur ça n'a rien à voir donc à
écouter poser quand même votre question
la perturbation venue d'irlande va se
déplacer vers la mer du nord fera beau
de la bretagne à la gironde
par contre dans le nord et dans l'est
temps sur la fin et le plus souvent très
nuageux entrecoupées d'averses sur la
normandie la région parisienne le centre
la région lyonnaise la savoie les
giboulées à talons avec de belles
périodes ensoleillées
le mistral soufflera en provence il
faudra presque aussi fois que le 4 mai
1954 14 degrés à paris c dans les
ardennes qu'il fera le plus frais 10
degrés dans les landes plus doux 17
degrés
c'est tout monsieur monsieur concurrents
suivants est-ce que c'est paris demont
chemise bloc
je ne suis plus que l'ombre de moi même
à quoi pensez-vous votre guide
mais j'ai un petit jeu on sent monsieur
monsieur de slim book qui est soumis ce
soir encore un mot perspicacité doit-il
être considéré comme une partie
indissociable d'un tout ou bien peut-il
être envisagé comme une entité concrètes
autonomes indépendantes ayant en quelque
sorte une vie propre qui lui seraient
personnel une question de la santé
affection ouais ben alors que la
réflexion c'est une question à laquelle
on pourrait répondre pour y répondre
d'une façon à la fois avec négative et
l'affirmative et un ans u20 quoi pensez
vous monsieur aubin un jeu de société
monsieur luc absolument pas alors là
monsieur non absolument désolé alors là
pas du tout
non non non absolument désolé parce que
m'a écouté nous sommes toujours désole
d'ailleurs de quitter des candidats
aussi valeureux que vous revoir monsieur
cet hommage aux grands suivant votre
truc qui peut être considéré comme un
instrument au service de la réaction et
quelle réaction monsieur concurrents
suivants dépêchez-vous l'heure tourne
dites moi monsieur guy lui ce monsieur
est ce que votre slim bus
peut servir à éclairer quelque chose ça
faisait un problème de de quel ordre de
quelle nature et de quel genre eu un
problème social évidemment à excellente
question monsieur malheureusement il
nous est interdit de répondre à ce genre
de questions la loi est formelle
merci beaucoup mais ton quand même 100
francs pour le geste du volet les
concurrents suivants s'il vous plaît tué
guy lux je dois vous dire que je vous
aime pas ça veut dire tout de suite
c'était pour votre bien bonjour
messieurs voilà main monsieur j'aurais
voulu savoir ce que je peux trouver le
schmilblick chez un brocanteur mais y
avez vous une autre question est ce que
je pourrais trouver le schmilblick chez
un antiquaire a répondu à cette question
je vous donne une dernière chance avec
une dernière question est ce qu'on peut
trouver le schmilblick chez un
ferrailleur
oui excellente question d'elle oui oui
abadie quoi il était temps attendait et
à quoi pensez-vous
oh rien c'était pour faire avancer le
smilblick cet amoureux des bleus oui ah
ah ah comme c'est d'un mal alors en cure
en suivant monsieur oui j'espère que tu
as le préfet a que ce qu'il vit à crédit
doivent fait de la concurrence
bon alors ce que perd une sincère à
aller désolé d'en voilà monsieur super
banco qui luxe il ya un petit problème
il ya ici deux messieurs qui ne veulent
en aucun cas se séparer
qu'est ce qu'on fait et bien fait les
passes et exceptionnellement à l'ewi
voilà alors est le schmilblick peut
servir de cataplasme à un coléoptère
asthmatiques ou deux pièges à rats
pendant ces étoiles retomber en enfance
ah non monsieur non suis désolé non ce
n'est pas ça est-ce que le cheminent
bloc peut servir de cible ah non non non
pas à ma connaissance non
et puis ensuite on a vu cette dame passé
je vous dis reconnu aujourd'hui comme si
difficile car ben dis donc je suis clair
oui bien sûr oui alors vous pouvez bien
entendu chaque mois ce sera pour faire
avancer bon bon bon très bien alors
dépêchez vous avant que je termine
connais votre question madame est bien
est ce que ça fait avancer
oui oui mais oui mais certainement pas
la mère précise est allé préciser votre
question nous y arrivons enfin à l'est
et bien à quelque chose qui ferait
amandine de swim adams en france en
france mais aux yeux des gens ok mais
quel bonheur d'avoir des concurrents
aussi perspicace
bravo madame à quoi pensez-vous à
quelque chose qui fait avancer si oui
voilà veuillez préciser bon sens nous
arrivons à la fin du jeu dépêchez vous
madame avant que le jeu ne se termine
vite
toute chose qui qui fait avancer le
smilblick mesalles y sommes à la marque
mais on n'est fait mais bravo madame
il s'agit du crépi chariot qui sert à
faire avancer le schmilblick
les chariots qui sert à faire avancer le
schmilblick
quatorze mille ha
mais oui
m
or et provinciales
pourquoi